jean marc bonjour 30 à 40 milliards
d'euros de pertes pour la franche des
chiffres catastrophiques et pourtant on
sait que les français sont massivement
partis en vacances comment expliquer par
rapport au total des recettes qui
habituellement arrive de la part du
tourisme
environ 180 milliards c'est la première
industrie française avec
l'agroalimentaire alors c'est paradoxal
parce que depuis le mois de juillet on a
eu des départs massifs
c'est vrai en direction des plages
françaises dans les régions côtières et
en ce début d'année est bien la plupart
des stations balnéaires sont passés
submergé de vacanciers ce qui pose
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
problèmes d'accueil de sécurité
d'hygiène aussi beaucoup pour les
municipalités en réalité les chiffres
sont ça premier point les français sont
massivement partie mais sont restés dans
l'hexagone
on estime qu'à peu près que d'ordinaire
il ya neuf millions de français qui sent
bon en espagne en italie ou ailleurs
aujourd'hui ils sont restés ils sont
restés en france donc c'est 9 millions
de touristes français qu supplémentaires
deuxième point vous avez toutes les
populations d'origine étrangère qui
d'ordinaire repartent dans leur pays
d'origine soit dans les familles du
maghreb au maroc en algérie ou ailleurs
elles sont restées en france parce que
leur pays est sous corona et qui a très
peu de transports possibles donc ces
familles et ces groupes de famille bien
sûr d'aller vers les côtes normandes
avec d'autant plus d'ailleurs d'entrain
de deux foriic que lise ont été confinés
pendant deux mois dans des conditions
compliquées difficile donc rués sur les
côtes normandes bretonne aquitaine
languedoc-roussillon
sans toujours avoir prévu ou organiser
un hébergement et puis le troisième
point est bien avant 10e les visiteurs
étrangers qui rapporte e des devises
chaque année à la demande et dans des
conditions assez morose à l'importante
biens sont pas là ils sont pas là les
américains sont pas venus les asiatiques
n'ont plus les européens du nord sont
plus rares que les autres qui a 17
millions de résidents étrangers qui ne
sont pas au rendez vous donc globalement
la france qui accueille chaque année 17
millions de touristes étrangers à fort
pouvoir d'achat ne les a pas trouvés et
puis vous avez ces français qui sont
restés beaucoup de français résident
très peu d'étrangers riches
d'où le trou probable de 30 à 40
milliards à cette faveur
jean-marc quels sont les professionnels
qui gagne et ceux qui perdent dans une
telle évolution
les grands perdants en ahl al aoula on a
perdu les 30 40 milliards d'euros ce
sont dans les hôtels et notre or
littoral parce que dans le littoral les
hôtels font à peu près là mais beaucoup
d'hôtels sont restés fermés c'est le cas
de paris ils resteront fermés en
attendant la clientèle étrangère
c'est le cas des grands perdants ce sont
les grands centres touristiques vous
savez ce qui attire énormément de
visiteurs de touriste versailles ou le
mont-saint-michel les châteaux de la
loire
les loueurs de rnb s'en sortent bien sur
la côte parce qu'elles font le plein le
problème c'est que la france n'est pas
équipé pour accueillir autant de
visiteurs les terrains de camping
déborde et puis le camping sauvage qui
s'est improvisé un peu partout crée
beaucoup de stress notamment pour les
locaux mais rapporte assez peu de
richesses et d'emplois c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs parce que vous avez beaucoup
d'écologistes en france qui se
félicitait de ce mouvement de ce retour
aux sources françaises dans la campagne
française et beaucoup il se félicitait
que les français restent en france
eh bien il commence un peu à déchanter
parce que l'accueil de telles quantités
de population est assez compliqué a
assuré dans des conditions écologiques
satisfaisante pour l'environnement au
niveau sanitaire honteux craintes de
beaucoup de plages aujourd'hui se
transporte en corona beach notamment à
cause évidemment du coc vide au niveau
de la sécurité c'est pas évident alors
l'été n'est pas terminé il ya aussi les
les trois prochains mois qui arrivent
des saisons où d'habitude on accueille
des touristes peuvent-ils justement
redresser ce bilan c'est vrai que
l'administration le secrétaire d'état au
tourisme
le disais hier espère que la saison va
pouvoir se prolonge et ils vont
d'ailleurs tout faire pour essayer de
l'allonger et accueillir notamment la
clientèle des du nord du nord de
l'europe les allemands les scandinaves
les hollandais l'administration espère
aussi que les américains ou les japonais
vont peut-être avoir envie de revenir en
europe choisie vous est la grande
inconnue c'est évidemment le virus 1 est
ce que la vague de vacanciers qui est
venu à la mer au mois d'août la
n'annonce pas une deuxième vague de
l'épidémie il faut continuer de se
protéger
évidemment la majorité de ceux ci
d'ailleurs assez étonnant un lama
était de ceux qui criaient au mois de
mars à paris parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de masque et bien auront du mal à les
mettre
lorsqu'ils sont sur la sur la plage cela
ne se précipite pas pour les mettre une
fois qu'ils sont en vacances
quant au pouvoir politique on a vu il
est assez flou il hésite encore beaucoup
à rendre obligatoire le port du masque
partout y compris d'ailleurs dans les
stations balnéaires
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
éditorialiste économique